happy relatively useless holiday okay so
it's once again Valentine's Day and I'm
gonna talk about this day mostly because
I've noticed that people have put
Valentine's Day as the judge jury and
executioner of the happiness of their
relationship yeah that blows
I mean you've noticed it people get
on Valentine's Day and it's like never
good enough I mean they can get like a
planet and then they'll being on the
phone with their friends that day I'll
like I know it's like it's I
just yeah he got me the earth but I mean
do you think he could have gotten me the
moon too I do nice thank you for you
really meant anybody got me the moon I
mean how much are ders that they gonna
need the moon now I'm not going to sit
here and tell you that my opinion on
Valentine's Day is fact cuz it's not I
mean by definition it's an opinion it's
not a fact I do however think that my
opinion is at least accommodated by a
bit of logic and I now share it with you
and I don't do it to be a dick I
actually do it because I do give a
but if anyone asks definitely it's
because I'm a dick so what has been
passed down for us to believe that
Valentine's Day this one day is the day
that matters when it comes to showing
your love for someone else who you
hopefully didn't find on Craigslist but
it says if February 14th is like a
magical day you show your love for
someone by giving them a materialistic
inanimate object that they really don't
need and if you do that on this day you
have like a plus 365 love XP so
ultimately it's really saying that
objects do matter I mean it's like those
people that only go to church on
Christmas it said why like I was in a
conversation with one of my family
members it was like it was Christmas Eve
and they were having midnight mass or
something like that at their church and
they were like are you going to church
on Christmas and I was like no I'm like
why not because I don't go the other
weeks of the year why would I go today
just feels forced and kind of douchey
the same principle applies to
Valentine's Day when you think about it
it's all in the math okay if you take
one day multiply it by a hundred and
divided by 365 you get the percentage of
the year that one day accounts for yes
it's point to 73 percent of the whole
year point two seven three point two
seven three percent is less than
one-third of one there's no way that
showing your love are not showing your
love for someone for point two seven
three percent of the year matters it
doesn't no I'm not saying don't do
something for someone for Valentine's
Day if you want to go for it I'm just
saying for the people out there who get
pissed off when someone doesn't you're a
surely getting mad over less than
one-third of 1% of the year I mean in
school if you brought home a test and it
was marked point to 73 percent of a
hundred your parents are not gonna hang
that on the fridge however the rest of
the year makes up ninety nine point
seven two percent of the year I mean I
would think that would be worth worrying
about a lot more and that's why it's not
Valentine's Day that matters it's the
year as a whole and I only bring this up
because Valentine's Day is literally
like an epidemic it is the fulcrum it's
on this pedestal as this thing that
means so much it's just another day now
when I say show your love the other 364
days of the year I'm not saying do corny
and buy cards every day no but on
the flip I'm not saying don't do
romantic things ever guys if you are in
a relationship you're gonna have to do
some romantic stuff even if your girl
says she doesn't want you to she does
it's just the way it is I'm just saying
if you appreciate each other year-round
and have things in perspective it's
amazing how one gimmick day a year
really doesn't mean I mean I could
find a married couple in a tribe
somewhere in the world in the middle of
BFA people who work with equipment so
primitive they make the Navi look like
lacuna suborn and they're as happy as
they can be and they do it without
Valentine's Day so people do not expect
your significant other to buy you a
bunch of on Valentine's Day that
you don't need because in reality that's
just materialistic be happy with who you
have and if you're not happy make a
change whatever it may be n ladies I
know Valentine's Day is this big deal
for you and if you've somehow gotten it
in your head that you're less because
you don't have someone on Valentine's
Day yeah that's just stupid please get
your head out of your ass yeah that's
all in the handbook of life I
don't know anywhere that it says that
you have to be with someone on a gimmick
day that was created to keep hallmark in
business god forbid a concept single and
happy try it you might even have fun so
what's your take on Valentine's Day
is it the pinnacle of all things love or
is it just another day that wall fun has
been put on a pedestal that's way too
high for its own good let me know and if
you somehow saw this because you typed
in Valentine's Day in the search bar and
it brought up this video of all others
and you've liked what you've seen here
click on the link in the sidebar to see
more until next time happy normal
everyday Sunday that isn't a holiday
whatsoever the happy Valentine's Day
you